We have a voicemail number, which you can
call anytime.
The numbers, two one nine two.
David P. here is just an absolutely delightful
caller saying my metaphore about crawling
over broken glass to vote for Biden.
She says it literally applies to her.
Take a listen to this.
Hi, David.
This is your father in law, Florida, who can
only get you on Facebook, too.
I just wanted to tell you that when you said
some people would crawl over broken glass
to vote.
I burst out laughing because it was funny.
But because you were describing me to a T..
I already voted by mail in my primary.
Good.
I'm 68 years old and I've been stressing for
four years.
So I'm likely to die from the virus.
But now I intend to wear a double mask and
turn in my ballot to vote in person.
Nothing will stop me from voting against Trump.
I just hope, beyond hope, there are enough
of us.
Keep up the great work, David.
What a caller.
Just absolutely fantastic.
And, you know, there's debates over who's
motivated, which party is more motivated or
less motivated or what.
It's going to come down to individuals like
our terrific caller who say I'm going to figure
out how to vote and whether I'm figuratively
crawling over broken glass, which includes
crawling, getting around the landmines of
voter suppression that are being placed out
there or literally crawling over broken glass
or what may be, you know, understaffed and
under-resourced polling places or whatever
the case may be, wearing two masks, etc. up.
She's going to figure out how to vote.
And that's ultimately what this election is
going to come down to.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
There is a call from pediatricians to end
these active shooter trainings that have become
very common in schools.
And their argument is that the trainings do
relatively little if there is actually an
active shooter.
It's such a chaotic situation that the trainings
really don't do much.
But the fact that the trainings are happening
may be traumatizing to students and may be
causing them to live in what is still statistically
an irrational fear given the low likelihood
of an active shooter scenario.
I want to talk about that.
The CDC has also removed its 14 day quarantine
guideline for people coming back from out
of state or overseas.
And I want to talk about why and whether it's
a science based decision or a politically
based decision.
We are also going to hear about more of the
protests that are re erupting.
We're going to hear from lawyers.
We're going to hear from protesters.
It's a crazy situation that is, again, developing.
I don't.
We know that it's getting the attention it
deserves and we're going to spend some time
on that on today's bonus show, so two ways
to get instant access to the bonus show.
Number one, become a member at join Pacman
dot com.
Number two, become a patron at Patrie on dot
com slash David Pakman show.
And then reminder, you can join me tonight
at quarter past eight, eight, 15 p.m. Eastern
for night three of the Republican National
Convention.
I'll be streaming live on YouTube and on Twitch.
I will see you then.